hey y'all this ain't Miley Cyrus now if
you've been paying attention to my
exploits you know damn well I've been
stuck in tener's Tower for a hot minute
well last week I was looking for a way
out and I went down a hallway I never
been down before and y'all ain't going
to believe this sh my goofy ass
accidentally fell into a dimensional
Schism and wound up trapped in the 15th
goddamn Dimension y'all it was wild they
had DMT space elves in cop outfits they
had dark matter hamburgers they had ampl
two hedron shers they had human
consciousness flavored Tater chips what
else do they have I don't know who cares
I'm still stuck ining tener's tower that
Schism spit my witchy ass back out right
where I went in so looks like I'm going
to be here for a while longer let
everybody know I'm doing all right I'm
just bored as hell and I'm sick of
eating tappy ERS for every goddamn
[Music]
meal